[Music]
good morning good afternoon good evening
wherever you are tuning in from thank
you so much for joining us
we're so excited to see you all here i'm
gonna
kick us off and say a little bit
about what today's event is going to
look like
i'm going to provide a brief
introduction to our global community
and then i'm going to introduce you all
to our panelists
i'll pitch a couple of questions to our
panelists as well
and then open it up to you all we really
want to make sure that you get all of
your questions answered today
and then um overall we're going to be
spending about 55 minutes together so
we're really looking forward to this
time
and getting your questions answered
so a little bit about what our global
community at stanford looks like
we have a truly global community as
i mentioned we have over 60 regional
alumni clubs around the world
um 30 000 gsb alumni globally
and as part of the gsb experience part
of this experience is expanding your
community and embracing
perspectives and experiences different
from your own i think one of our
greatest assets is the
diversity of our community and that
opportunity to learn from your peers
and that's something that we really
really value we also have a
global education requirement it is our
expectation
that you will learn from your peers and
learn from
other leaders around from around the
world
we have over 50 clubs and organizations
including regional interest groups such
as the africa business club
the business and india club the europe
club the greater china business club
the latin american student association
and the middle east and north africa
club
i would love for you all to meet our
panelists as well
um let me see kenji why don't you get us
started tell us a little bit about
yourself
hi everyone uh this is kenji tateiwa
stanford mba class of 2004.
um so i currently work for a japanese
utility tokyo electric power company
and uh i've always worked for this
company before the gsb and after gsp
which is quite
unusual as a gsp but um i've been
working for the same company
for a reason and that is because i want
to create a perfect energy world
providing clean safe affordable energy
in a reliable way and i firmly believe
that i have the
best chance of making a positive impact
to the world by
transforming tepco a big incumbent uh
slow moving dinosaur utilizing my gsb
skill sets so
uh that's what i've been uh doing uh
looking forward to
talking with you all of you thanks thank
you kenji and i should note kenji is
also one of our
mvps in our meet and alum program i know
so often prospective students want to
talk to our students and our alumni
kenji has been hosting events every
saturday for the past year so
if you can't get enough of kenji today
take a look at our events calendar
and you could have the opportunity to
talk to kenji more directly in a in a
more intimate setting
so thank you for that kenji yeah thanks
um
do you like to introduce yourself sure
hey everyone and uh hello also to
jessica will and
and kenji uh kenji we last caught up at
the uh gsb singapore apac
conference uh i think about a year and a
half ago before ah that's right yeah
good to see you nissan
before the world fell apart uh but as a
as a quick
introduction uh you know i'm originally
from india i grew up in
in perth in western australia uh
started my career as an engineer in the
oil and gas industry here
so for those of you familiar with perth
it's one of the energy hubs of the world
i think uh quite fast after after
starting the work i
i realized that um there were folks who
could probably do
engineering a lot better than me and you
know applied to the business school at
stanford and was fortunate enough to
to get in i've since spent over a decade
working across southeast asia originally
in singapore but
soon after that i was moved to vietnam i
was in
hanoi for a year and a half from hanoi
to manila
in between spent some time in kl
and been working across a range of
industries so
unlike kenji who's had the fortitude to
uh
uh you know excel uh with with one
company i've been involved with a few
different ventures and
happy to talk about them in more detail
uh i currently run my own
startup in partnership with my wife
who's a gsb class
of 2011 grad focused on the mother and
child
e-commerce space here in the philippines
and also advising a regional private
equity group called creador on the
philippine investments and operations
awesome thank you so much for that
introduction
and tanvi thank you for being here you
want to introduce yourself
uh yes thank you jessica and apologies
to everyone for not being on screen
earlier i didn't realize i was
named something else on zoom because you
can't change your name in a webinar
so i was just struggling i was just
struggling with that
uh definitely not
appropriate to be the youngest member in
the panel if it doesn't
it's not operating zoom pro properly but
we'll we'll move past that
um so i graduated from
uh stanford last year uh june 2020
straight into the pandemic
i am based in delhi right now and i also
grew up
in delhi i my background prior to the
business school was
in in philanthropy and i was interested
in social entrepreneurship
during the business school i started a
social venture called tamarind chutney
which is a sustainable and ethical
a barrel brand and i fully credit
stanford's various resources
and sort of giving me that push and i've
been doing that since i'm very excited
to answer any questions today
awesome thank you all so much for those
introductions
um so before we get into q a
i do want to let our attendees know that
this is just
one stop along your journey if you
haven't already created
a mystanford.mba dashboard
i strongly encourage you to do that so
you can keep in touch with us you can
browse our events get personalized
information
tailored to your interests so strongly
encourage you all to do that
i'm now going to stop sharing my screen
so you can see us
all a little bit better and get us
started with a couple questions
so for our attendees please feel free to
submit your questions in our q
a box for our panel you can also upvote
other attendees questions if you see
something that addresses
any of your interests so i'll get us
started uh for our panelists i'm curious
uh what made you decide to pursue
an mba and why
why specifically a stanford mba
so shall i go first sure yeah yeah
hi hi so everyone uh so again uh kenji
tatia class of
2004. um so i joined tokyo electric
power company or tepco in 1996
uh after uh getting my bachelor's and
master's in nuclear engineering
so i was working for tepco as a nuclear
engineer initially at the fukushima
daini nuclear power station
and then at the headquarters in the
nuclear engineering department
and i was uh special specializing in uh
nuclear safety design for the next
generation nuclear reactors
collaborating with companies such as
general electric toshiba and hitachi
and i was proud of what i was doing and
was determined to continue my career as
a nuclear engineer
but then in early 2000s there was this
u.s
energy company called enron uh some of
you may remember enron
enron was in its pinnacle in the early
2000s came into the japanese market
and there was rumors that mrami tried to
take over japanese utilities
and i thought that the typical
management was not up to the task in
fending off enron
and i learned that the enron executives
had this thing called an mba which i did
not know
at the time so i i looked up what it was
and then decided i should get one myself
and then started my application process
and why stanford uh there are myriads of
reasons but
one of the more important reasons was
that
stanford gsb has this culture which was
at the opposite end of the spectrum
compared to tepco
the old slow-moving bureaucratic company
whereas at the stanford gsb
it's the cutting-edge entrepreneurial uh
agile uh environment where i can learn
more of that spirit and bring it back to
tepco and transform that company so that
was
one of the reasons i chose where
stanford was
my green dream school
awesome thank you for that
cool i'm happy to go next if we're going
by graduating year
so uh yeah nisha nish again uh
from manila philippines uh and i guess
the uh the mba decision was fairly
straightforward
for for me uh as an engineer uh with
you know a core engineering background
uh say the engineering degrees in in the
likes of australia similar to most of
the commonwealth uh you know tend to be
very technical
uh very focused in terms of engineering
itself
so you know the if you if you do an
undergrad degree in the in the us
if you major in engineering you could
still take a bunch of classes
in in business to you know religious
education to ice skating and everything
in between and
i think you know come out with a very
well-rounded education even if you
your degree says engineering right in my
case uh
you know i think 95 of my classes were
engineering focused um i started my
career as an engineer
more as a project manager and it was a
dream engineering job so for
for any engineers uh listening uh you
know
uh i think uh certainly um the the role
i was in was not a
motivating factor it was more uh i think
a desire to broaden organizational focus
so i loved what i was doing i spent
uh time on the back deck of ships in the
middle of the ocean
supervising underwater operations with
remote submarines and you know tiger
sharks circling the boat and
uh it was a lot of fun uh but i think uh
wanted a flavor of how companies ran
uh outside of just the the technical
project management uh
arena right and how did they work from
the standpoint of strategy
marketing finance and an mba was a a
very
um good solution in terms of uh
providing that uh
that uh i guess the uh the rounding over
there right
uh why stanford i had visited stanford
as an undergrad
uh i studied on exchange at the
university of illinois and i had a
distant uncle who i
visited in in northern california and
uh he took me around showed me the
campus and i think
you know if any of you guys have visited
uh stanford uh
you you fall in love with it pretty fast
right and so always wanted to go there
you know a tremendous brand um a
wonderful reputation of collaboration
um at that point of time uh you know the
energy space was
was very exciting lots of innovations
happening in the valley with clean tech
and and other innovations
it fit right into my background and
energy and then finally the
entrepreneurial spirit
yeah you know whether um i wasn't sure
whether i wanted to
jump into being an entrepreneur right
after the mba or do it down the line and
but i knew whatever i did uh taking that
eye for converting entrepreneurial
opportunity
into tangible results was something that
stanford could give me and uh here i am
10 years on awesome thank you
tanvi you want to close us out sure so
um i actually applied to business school
in my la
final year in my senior year of college
as a deferred admit so i was like 20
21 years old i mean i think at that time
i'm not sure if there are too many
people here looking for deferred
admission but i can go into it a little
bit i think at that time
i had just heard from an older colleague
slash mentor at one of my internships so
this is a cool program
to do to sort of give you flexibility
and freedom to you know
like if you get into business school in
college then the next three to four
years you can
explore a little bit and and and
experiment and
and you know try a bunch of things so
that's why i i applied
it was definitely a sort of nothing to
lose situation because i
still had to find a job but once i got
in i felt like i could then you know
take the plunge and do something a
little more risky in the sense i went
for a slightly less known brand for my
first job
uh so that was great but i think
you know to something that might help
applicants that are applying in the
regular cycle
um i feel like i realize more
retrospectively um for people
maybe in the development sector or for
people that have
slightly unconventional not not
business background i think stanford is
really the place to be
uh because of how diverse the class is
because of how entrepreneurial the class
is i mean i have
friends at other business schools where
you know
60 of the class is going into consulting
or finance and then if you're not that
person you really
feel the pressure that everybody has got
a job by january and i have no idea what
i'm doing
and i think at stanford because there's
so many people trying startups
looking at different firms in the bay
area that have very different recruiting
cycles
you're never alone at any point being
like okay you know everybody has a job
and i don't and it really
helped me not get into peer pressure and
explore things that i wanted to um so
that was great i think it's much more
laid back in that way uh in a good way
and i
also felt like um the class size or you
know being a little smaller was really
good to
have a more intimate experience i
definitely felt like i
if not knew every classmate of mine
personally but at least
know them by face and by name and i
could definitely reach out to them and
they wouldn't be like wait who are you
are you sure in the same class
and i think that that um familiarity was
also
really great and i probably didn't know
that i didn't think about it at 20 but
um as i was going through stanford i
felt like you know i
was very lucky that you know i didn't
know these things but i still landed up
at stanford and found the right fit for
me
awesome thank you for that um so i'm
gonna turn to
our attendee q a now and
paul asked a great question that was
actually on my list of questions as well
paul wants to know what are the stanford
resources opportunities or experiences
that helped equip you for a career in
asia
i can i can start so
i think i mean i grew up in india um
and so you know coming back to india was
always something that i was
i was really interested in but i uh i
think stanford definitely helped me
learn
like keep my knowledge about india up
and also learn about other parts of asia
most specifically
china so about india i
was part of the business in india club
and we organized a lot of talks
um and and sort of called speakers in
did
events with companies in the bay area
that maybe
were focused on india or had india
offices and i think that was really
great i didn't feel like okay because i
was away
from india for two years i had lost
track and then there were all kinds of
events that were happening various
elections this that and the other
and there was always conversation about
it so there's definitely that community
but i the other thing that i feel like
stanford really
uh helped me learn about was china i
probably didn't know anything about
china especially as in indian i had you
know like i knew about china because
chinese goods are everywhere in india
but i didn't really have any sort of
academic or business
perspective and i took
um i mean i took uh my global study trip
was to china so that was really really
great
that was in the spring of my first year
that got me very interested i took two
more courses
on china through the business school one
on the political economy and one more on
financial systems
and then i also led a global seminar to
china i'm not sure in this pandemic
situation
how many of these global experiences are
relevant but
um it was really really great um
i think i went from knowing nothing to
be able to you know
like i'm obviously i'm definitely not an
expert but i think i can now sustain my
own
knowledge in the sense that you know i
can read more i can like pick up a book
or something i reach a stage where i'm
like okay i can keep on learning by
myself
and i think um i focused on china just
because interested
in in asia and emerging economies
there's so many other people who focused
on
southeast asia for instance japan like
there are study trips there are classes
there are clubs so
i think if you go in within a specific
interest you can always
find the resources that that will help
you learn more and also then there'll be
other people who are interested as well
cool thanks dan we uh that was that was
great um
i think in my case uh i focus on maybe
three aspects right i think one is
uh you know your classmates right i
think
uh in my close to 40 percent i think of
students were
international might be more now uh
significant portion of them from
from asia um and australasia
and so i think firstly just you know
meeting these incredibly accomplished
classmates from
from china from thailand from uh
all across southeast asia and asia of
course i'm i'm also originally indian so
uh
very familiar with india's landscape but
like town we learned a lot about china i
learned a lot about the other markets in
in asia japan right korea so that was
one
one element i think was was hugely
enlightening and these all
you know folks from different
backgrounds different walks of life uh
different personalities and it was a
great fun getting to know them
the other aspect were classes and and of
course uh
even lecturers uh you know so i took uh
classes such as global context and
management that helps sort of
crystallize some uh frameworks and so on
when approaching international markets
what are the key challenges you'd face
there
you know things like facilitating
payments and
you know regulatory environments and
things like that that you you might not
be
uh coming across quite as often in in
the likes of
australia right or or the us or canada
uh and uh lecturers as well i mean you
had uh how lee for example who was uh
you know one of
the thought leaders when it comes to
global operations and
uh you know learning firsthand from from
someone like him
about supply chains in hong kong for
example and china was amazing
and then finally was a global
experiences so i undertook
the stanford chingua exchange program
called step
uh jessica can confirm whether that's
that's something that's still uh
still being offered uh but that was a
fantastic learning opportunity because
you got paired up with students from
chingua's international mba program and
you got to work on actual projects
together so
uh we uh and myself and another partner
paired up with a couple of students in
chingua university to to study the
renewable energy landscape in china and
learnings applicable to the
the us and other markets at the time so
uh
those are few approaches uh there's
obviously many more uh i'm sure kenji
can also
share some of those
yeah uh just a little bit a little bit
about the gsb network
in japan are there about uh 600 alumni
uh gsb alumni including uh the second
year program
uh the uh one year on msx and then the
uh the several weeks um sap executive
program and i've been on the leadership
team of the gsb japan chapter since i
graduated
in 2004 so i got to know many or most of
the alumni here
so and the network is very strong and
although in my case
i'm in this niche nuclear industry so i
have been
been directly utilizing much of the dsp
network however
uh the various events going on it
allows you to tap into different um uh
expertise and get to know a lot of
people so
other alumni they are um utilizing that
network for
uh finding uh new opportunities and so
forth
so thank you for that um we have a
couple questions
about entrepreneurship
at the gsb and i often find that this is
a very common
interest among our prospective students
um so i see a couple questions directed
towards tanvi
and uh nishanna you're also an
entrepreneur can you comment
on some of the entrepreneurial resources
and opportunities at the gsb and how
they supported your
entrepreneurial ventures post gsb
sure uh happy to go go first
i mean i think that the gsb and and
entrepreneurship are almost uh
uh i mean they are uh inextricably sort
of connected right
i mean so many of uh the world's most
amazing
companies were formed uh as a result
directly or indirectly because of
stanford university
uh that in turn was part of uh it's its
location in the middle of silicon valley
and it's sort of a chicken and
egg thing there right the valley also
sprung up around stanford stanford
has benefited hugely from having the
silicon valley ecosystem around it
and i i think just being in that
environment alone
is something that you know permeates
everything at stanford right it
permeates a classroom
it permeates your interactions inside
and outside of campus
uh so you are exposed to basically
some of the hottest startups on the
planet just a stone's throw away
from you in palo alto or elsewhere in
the bay area
you're learning from lecturers who've
not just
you know sort of lectured in the
classroom but many of whom have actually
gone out and started
extremely successful companies then come
back to sort of share their learnings
you have talks from from business
leaders
uh from from bill gates uh through to uh
you know the top vc venture capitalists
in
in the country uh at any given point of
time
you know every week so i think it's
something that you you really can't
uh escape uh for for better for worse
right but clearly for the
for the better and uh
you know it's a hugely inspiring
environment to be in because
it helps you if you came in for example
saying hey i want to be an entrepreneur
and i want to start a company and you
know
be fantastic if i could start a company
of 100 people and you know do 10 million
revenue or whatever it is right that'll
be a great lifestyle
uh you come out of the gsb and you're
like hey you know i want to start a
a company employing 10 000 people and uh
you know that's a unicorn right and
there's a billion dollar plus company
right and
and it's it's it's really that kind of
um inspiration
and um i guess the tools that you get
equipped uh through
the classroom through your classmates
through lecturers through the ecosystem
the internships available to you and so
on that
really prepare you for a career in
entrepreneurship uh
post gsb
awesome thank you tandy you want to
chime in
sure so i mean i think like
i echo a lot of what nishan said about
you know
people like just stanford being part of
the ecosystem i think
um in general what business school also
gives you is just space to experiment
right like you know you can try
something out like in your summer break
through classes and if it
works you can run with it if it doesn't
it's okay you can do something else and
that sort of risk
like it really lowers the risk and
stanford is better than i think most
schools than that because of like its
proximity
to to like you know the bay area and
also entrepreneurial culture so they
were
like there are classes that i took uh
for instance
startup garage is one of them where you
basically get
like you know advice from vcs and
and entrepreneurs that have started and
funded successful silicon valley
companies on your idea
and you also can get like b like really
like not funding but you can get like a
thousand dollars here and there to play
with your idea run some
ads make some light you know mock-up of
a product
and and you know like that stuff
really really goes a long way i mean i
think it generally goes a long way if
you're building for asia it goes an
even longer way um i think like with my
stipend
and coming back to india i used it for
months and months um so
i think those sort of classes the center
for ces i think it's called for the
entrepreneurial study center csi the
center for social innovation
there's so many coaches and mentors
there that sort of help you workshop
your ideas
uh give you feedback connect you to
people um you know
and then i think if you have an idea
any other class can sort of become
something that you apply to your idea so
for instance i when i took my
communications classes in my second year
i got better at pitching for my idea
when i took my writing class i wrote an
op-ed like you know you could like
totally
i mean you don't have to do this but you
could literally fit your idea in
whatever
practical classes that you want and you
can make progress on various
aspects of your own development or your
idea so um
i think there's you know while obviously
like i went
personally i think i went a little bit
extra in the sense that i
i did um like start working on my
business through business school and
that has
negatives like it gets very stressful
but i think the advantage is that you
can really use
all these resources uh to your to your
benefit and i think that was great
that's awesome thank you for that um
next there's a really lovely question
from tian yin
who asks what is the biggest impact your
gsb experience
has created on your career and your life
i'm going to start with kenji
who um as you all might see in the chat
has
dropped some of his information and has
clearly had a very illustrious
career and life post gsb um
so kenji what is the biggest impact gsb
has had on your career in life so far
yeah thanks um so let me um talk about
two
um anecdotes uh one is uh
the pre um march 11 2011 fukushima
accident
uh so before that um after getting my
mba in 2004
i uh spearheaded tesco's overseas
nuclear business
and i got to use many of the gsb skill
sets in negotiating a deal
uh to for tepco to become uh the first
japanese utility to invest in an
in an overseas nuclear project uh in
texas uh
us um and then uh the biggest impact was
uh during the fukushima nuclear crisis
uh
after march 11 2011 and
uh the the touchy feely course that many
of you probably have heard
uh came in handy in an unexpected manner
when i had one when i was asked by the
technical management
uh to tur to serve as a facilitator and
coordinator between the united states
nuclear industry team uh who came to the
tepco headquarters in late march 2011
to provide technical support to tepco to
combat the fukushima crisis but because
it was uh like chaotic um the temple
management
was not uh ready to make the most out of
the
very very generous offer from the u.s
team and so i was
asked to uh talk with the leader
of the u.s team where i got to use the
touchy-feely technique
in having communication
in an american way where i asked
the leader of the u.s team may i ask you
why your team came to japan on an
empty airplane when people were fleeing
japan out of fear of radiation
whereas you your team came to japan and
offered
and you're offering typical free
technical advice that sounds too good to
be true
and the leader of the u.s team actually
appreciated my
candid candor in an american way and he
gave me two reasons
why the u.s team came to japan to
support tepco
reason one number one was because the
global nuclear community
uh we're on the same boat if someone's
having an issue it's everyone else's uh
shared uh issue and because the u.s
nuclear industry had the most expertise
if they felt that it was their
responsibility in supporting tepco
reason number two was because the
fukushima nuclear reactors were
originally designed by general electric
the u.s team had to understand what
caused the accident
what are the lessons learned to bring
back those lessons
to the us to ensure safety of their
nuclear fleet
and that kind of communication allowed
me to understand that the interest
between tepco and the u.s nuclear
industry
were completely aligned in tackling the
crisis together and
we were able to form a very strong team
in
uh solving many of the uh very complex
issues
on a daily basis and that was thanks to
the touchy feely course
i took a long time ago back in 2002 a 3
2004 time frame
thank you for sharing that um
nish tanvi any reflections on
the impact gsb has had on your life and
career
yeah i think though the one word that
would somehow sum it up would be people
and uh you know the the lifelong
relationships you end up making at the
gsb right and
i think tanvi had touched upon it
earlier but
you know the gsb is a relatively small
class size
and i think that really translates into
really deep bonds
uh you're almost in an environment where
everyone's like family
you know it's a it's a real community
and
the thing that i i guess i didn't
appreciate uh and i can appreciate now
with sort of 10 years of
plus of hindsight is that it's a
lifelong journey so
you know you make some great friends
over there uh i think first and foremost
uh
uh you know which in my case was was
meeting my wife there right and i was
assigned to be uh her her buddy the
stanford has this buddy program
where um you know you're kind of like an
informal mentor to a incoming second
year student and
so she says i think i took advantage of
my position i say i took my
responsibilities very seriously
but uh you know in addition to that as
well you know made some
some fantastic friends and um you know
ten plus years down the line
uh our parts cross you know you meet you
go to you
to paris on business uh you know
somebody passes through manila for a
holiday
and you know you didn't really know them
that well in in in school but thanks to
facebook and stuff you you
you drop them a line you say hey i'm
passing through town let's catch up
and you really hit it up and you have
these deep uh sort of conversations and
you said hey you know where were you for
for two years when i was at business
school right and
so uh i think the people you meet uh and
it's not just purely from a friendship
standpoint right i think it just
uh completely opens your your mind in
ways that you never thought possible
uh you know it sort of expands
uh your thinking right um and then
i'd say from the standpoint of even
career like i've been involved with a
few different ventures post-business
school so i started
my career outside of or following
stanford
with a u.s power company developing and
investing in power plants across
uh southeast asia uh initially got in
touch with the president of
of asia in that that company through a
stanford introduction
right uh i moved on uh you know started
uh in in the philippines a
coconut farming and processing company
an agritech venture
uh got in touch with this person through
the uh
who is also a gsb who graduated about 10
years before me
again through the local alumni
association right when i wanted to move
on to an investment career
an introduction was made to a founder of
this private equity firm again through
one of my my gsb classmates
and right now i'm running a an
e-commerce venture uh
in partnership with my wife who's also
gsv right so
it's been uh it's been impactful in um
sort of myriad ways but but people is uh
first and foremost
i think i'm too early in my career to
have definitive answers
but both i think kenji and nishan sounds
very exciting for me and i'm looking
forward to see how it plays out
[Music]
thank you all um there are a few
questions that i'm going to try to bring
together
and you all have provided so many rich
examples
of the ways that you've used the
skills and resources and opportunities
at the gsb
to how you've used them in your career
there are several more questions about
sort of the specific skills or
networks programs alumni base
and how how you've used them to
support your current work
so any any further reflection there i
feel like we've heard several great
examples but
would love to hear more yeah one one
other
um example related to the fukushima
nuclear crisis
uh was about this uh the greater
stanford university network in japan
um when in 2011 the earthquake and
tsunami and the nuclear accident
happened
the u.s ambassador to japan was
ambassador john roos
who is a stanford law school alumnus and
i had known the ambassador
uh prior to the earthquake tsunami and
accident
through the japan stanford association
network as i was board member for the
japan stanford association
and um so so the the jsa members were
invited to the ambassadors of show
residence in uh
in tokyo uh to watch the football game
between stanford and
uc berkeley the the big game uh stanford
one by the way um
but so i had known the ambassador and
when the accident happened and the
united states us
provided humanitarian support to japan
uh
with regard to the tsunami victims and
also supported
the nuclear crisis there was a
get-together
in june 2011 at the ambassador's
residence with hundreds of
americans in japanese who responded
together
as a team and although there were
hundreds of people and many senior
people
i i found um i saw the ambassador and
walked up to him
and uh told him i'm kenji from the
stanford event and he happened to
remember me
and i told him i happened to be a
typical nuclear
uh engineer and i wanted to thank the
ambassador for the united states support
to
japan and tepco and that would not have
been possible without the stanford
network because the ambassador is a very
senior person and i was a nobody of
tepco
but anyway so that that shows uh the
strong
bond not just within the gsb circle but
also the step
greater stanford university network
thank you for that i'm sure you were not
a nobody at topco
um but yeah i hear um i hear from our
students all the time that
part of the benefit of going to the gsb
is that access to
the rest of campus the rest of community
being able to take classes
as we say across the street in a variety
of different disciplines and departments
so i'm glad to hear that that
that extends beyond just classes to
the greater community yeah
sean tell me any additional reflections
on
some of the experiences opportunities
courses that have had a big
impact or have supported your careers in
asia
sure um so i think kenji already talked
a lot about touchy feely
i second all of that a really i mean a
good course that sort of helped me
become more effective as as a leader
a communicator and i think um
a lot of like stanford's courses around
soft skills
um you know managing people coaching
people
are really really helpful in in sort of
my day-to-day work in ways that i didn't
realize i think when i was there
i was like oh this is great but like how
will i use it in the real world
and then you know you step into the real
world and you're like oh it does you
know matter how exactly you give
feedback it does matter
um to sort of you know chart out like
for instance with me and my co-founder
we have daily check-ins all the time
about work but we also have
check-ins that are more about like okay
how are you feeling about the business
about growth about the fact that
whatever like you know that
running an e-commerce fashion business
in the pandemic
just has its own challenges so it's been
a tough year
and sort of char you know carving out
that time
uh to talk about not business and tasks
but to really talk about where we're at
is definitely something that that i
learned and internalized very much
at stanford at gsb through these classes
through touchy feely through the
arbuckle leadership leadership
leaders fellowship which was also a
really really good opportunity to work
on
on these things and i think um in
general i've
i used all these classes as ways to
work on challenges that i had
professionally earlier whether it was
conflict management or being more
assertive or just
aspects that i had gotten feedback on in
my previous jobs these classes were
really great
places to try out new behaviors and then
to sort of
go out into the real world and say okay
now i can do this now you know
i'm not you know like i'm okay to say no
to in a meeting without it turning into
a crazy conflict or whatever
uh so i think these small small things
that i
learned at the gsb actually have a
really big impact on how i i can
handle meetings and and interactions
with different different stakeholders
and
and i think yeah i mean i definitely
didn't even have any of these
uh skills to to you know use
uh before the gsb
thank you for that yeah and i think
great uh
great examples by kenji and tanvi uh
a couple of uh classes that stood out
for me uh i mean well firstly you know
the
the sort of entrepreneurial classes
right that really play uh
very tangibly into the career have right
now the likes of formation of new
ventures and so on being taught by
uh again seasoned uh entrepreneurs and
business leaders in the valley
uh one softest skill class that was was
fantastic and legendary was managing
growing enterprises
which was taught by er grossbeck who was
uh
one of the owners or was one of the
owners of the boston celtics and uh
you know created the concept of a search
fund uh back in
in the 80s right where you you set up a
fund to to go and acquire
a company and then grow that and
generate returns for the investors
and that class was all about uh
basically situations in these high
growth companies where
uh difficult situations difficult
conversations that you had to have
and frameworks in order to approach such
situations right and
then we would actually have very real
life cases about
these situations uh we were cold called
and uh you know had to kind of play out
uh how we we think we should handle this
right and
uh plan out conversations and things
like that
and at the end of the class we would
often have uh the actual
protagonists in the case are present to
tell us what actually happened
you know and sometimes it might be in
line with how students have played it
out and sometimes it was complete
curveballs right like that you would
you never expect how that situation
really ended right and
they talk about their regrets or talk
about you know very candidly about uh
you even once had uh you know the the
founders of bonobos who came in right
and
at that point of time they had already
split up right and so they talked very
candidly about
what worked what didn't work and you
know i thought that was
quite remarkable
yeah that sounds really fascinating um
there's a great question from sarab
um and tommy i think you touched on this
a little bit describing
sort of the culture of vulnerability at
stanford but sarab is wondering
um if you had to describe the on-campus
culture at stanford in one word
what would it be i love that question
i think maybe i would go with
authenticity i think there's a
like but yeah i feel like i felt like i
was allowed to just be
who i was without thinking so much about
okay what are these
what what am i supposed to do and i
think given all these classes about
you know vulnerability and giving
feedback like people say no feedback is
a gift that's what
we keep like saying at the gsb so i
think there's
even like a very intentional focus on on
being authentic um through like the
classes the curriculum and
the overall culture
i i would say on yeah uh uh
in addition to tami's uh comment um
maybe
perhaps collaborative uh so yeah
all classmates are super smart people
but um
there's a culture of teaching each other
so in my case as a nuclear engineer i
could ask
stupid financial questions to my former
investment banker
classmates and then vice versa i could
teach some uh
engineering classes to uh
non-engineering uh background
classmates uh so that was okay and uh
for me
uh having uh educated in japan
uh the american way of proactive
participating classroom style was
foreign to me
so i struggled initially to
raise my hand and speak up but
when i gradually tried to do so uh
one day my class classmate slipped me a
note saying
that was a great comment kenji which
encouraged me to speak up more
and uh and and provide value to the
class uh discussion so
that's a kind of collaborative uh
atmosphere at the gst
yeah i totally echo uh tanvi and kenji
and uh you know uh instead of adding on
to those words right a sort of embellish
it with another example uh
in um in my first my very first quarter
had a a classmate from
from nigeria who's uh whose father
passed away
uh you know very tragically and he had
to fly back
all the way to nigeria you know he came
back a week or two
later you know obviously very distraught
and so on having to
sort of get back into class and uh
we had this was just before our exams
right and this
this guy came from a marketing
background um
and we had a tough finance class uh
coming up in in in a week right uh and i
had another classmate who did
finance uh as an undergrad degree right
and uh despite
all that you have going on and you know
tanvi and kenji will attest to the fact
that
the gsb can can be quite overwhelming
just with the sheer
volume of of things going on at any
given point of time right talks on
campus
off campus academics you know job
sort of hunting and networking and
things like that
this guy took about i would say 10 hours
out over
three days so about two to three hours
every every evening after
after classes ended to coach uh
our classmate uh in finance before the
exam
just to get him up to speed on like the
last uh you know two weeks or whatever
he missed right because of his
um this family tragedy right and that's
the extent when we talk about
uh collaboration and empathy and you
know uh
vulnerability right that's the extent of
support and and
that's um that's what the stanford bonds
translate to right
and i think in part it's also shaped by
uh the west coast business culture right
which is
uh very much entrepreneurial very much
about value creation
it's like hey you know i'd say the east
coast business culture tends to be sort
of
you know shaped maybe a little bit more
by wall street right like if uh
uh i grow my slice of the pie that's a
little bit less pie than you're getting
right whereas i think in in the west
it's hey you know if uh
you know you have a pie i i'll just
create another pie and then we can
both sort of share pies right and so um
it's a it's a culture i think that that
tends to permeate stanford as well and
uh
yeah a very uh a very transformational
place to be thank you for sharing those
stories i think those were all such
beautiful illustrations of what our
what our community and our culture are
like sushi so thank you for that
um yukio asked an interesting question
and i'll
read their question and then maybe
reframe it a little bit so yukio asks i
suppose the world and asia have been
changing a lot
after you graduated from gsb if you were
to go to gsb again now what would you
like to do
and perhaps another way of thinking of
that question might be if you could do
it all again
what would you do differently were there
any surprises were there any
opportunities that you wish you'd taken
advantage of what would you do
differently if you were to
to do the experience over if anything
so yeah go ahead okay okay
so yeah short anecdote so not
specifically related to asia but
what i regret one of the um the biggest
regrets that i have uh during my gsb
years was that i took this course called
entrepreneurial thought leaders seminar
where prominent entrepreneurs came to
the gsb and gave inspirational
inspirational talks there was an option
to
go see the speaker in person or you
could watch it online
and i was very busy uh on a certain day
and uh so i chose the online version and
the speaker of the day was a guy called
elon musk
with spacex and i because i had met
jeff bezos in person i've seen steve
jobs in person
at the dsb i thought i could skip this
guy and i would regret it to date
but that shows how much opportunity they
are out there at the dsp and you have to
prioritize
and sometimes you do make mistakes so if
i could go to gsp again
i'll go meet uh elon musk wow who knows
you could have been
in space this week if you had gone to
class
oh yeah on that note one of my most
memorable experiences
is uh having a lunch with just half a
dozen others with carlos gone
right of a renault nissan fame or
you know an authority at the moment
right
but uh you know coming back
to to jessica's uh question i'd say
though the one regret i i did have is is
maybe
taking maybe not taking one or two
classes
uh more across the street as they say in
stanford right
and i think when you're in the gsp it's
such an all-consuming bubble because
there's so much going on
uh you know and then you're just excited
to get to know your classmates and
uh network for that dream job and you
know learn so much in terms of all the
cool classes going on
that you tend to forget that stanford as
a whole is a is an incredible
institution right i mean you've got a
a university that's uh amongst the top
in in almost every discipline that is
offered there right so
besides uh business school clearly
engineer
sorry engineering law earth sciences
education
and and of course the design school uh
you know i think that's probably my
personal regret
uh you know taking a class at the design
school or not taking a class at the
design school and
and understanding things from a a design
standpoint right the product development
for example from a design standpoint
versus
sort of the business approach which is
more you know sort of hey where's the
market need and
going coming at it from a completely
different lens
so for those of you who are fortunate
enough to get in uh to stanford and get
into the gsb
um you know it's not just the gsp
stanford it's not just a gsb it's a lot
more than that and so
so do research in advance sort of plan
out
you know a couple of the cool classes in
in other schools that you might want to
take in advance and then once you get
there figure out how to get in
yeah and very similar even i was going
to say uh that i think
i thought i would take a lot of across
the street classes as many as i would be
allowed but i would get so excited about
all the gst classes that i didn't and i
think
i wish i had taken a computer science
course and on the other side of the
spectrum i wish i'd taken an english
course
uh just because i think you can of
course take
like that courses on course era but to
be in an environment like of this like
super
amazing large research university with
all these resources
in front of you i mean i i think yeah i
just wish i'd
made more use of that like in stanford
outside
in the gsb outside the gsp and yeah i
mean i think
those would be two for me
awesome well i know we are coming up on
time so i want to thank our panelists so
much
for spending your a bit of your day with
us um
this has been really illuminating for me
and i'm sure it's been really
illuminating for
our attendees as well um and a big thank
you to our
attendees we love that you've spent the
past hour with us
please let us know how we're doing and
the feedback pool these events are for
you and we want to know how
how we are doing and how we're serving
you we have many many more events coming
up this summer
so please stop by our events page and
see
what else is going on and we have a
series of events in a couple weeks the
first week of august
called application week we'll have
workshops and panels
all about getting through that
application process
because we want to make sure that you
get across the finish line and have all
of your questions answered
so thank you again to our panelists to
our attendees we're so glad that you
spent a bit of your time with us today
um our panelists any last
quick parting words of advice you'd like
to give our attendees before we
before we close out
i will like just like to say that uh the
two years at the dsp was a paradise
but a very extremely challenging
paradise
i love that awesome well thank you all
nishanti had something to say well i was
going to just say thanks everyone for
your time i know it's
very early in the morning for some
people and you know
probably more orders for others so uh
appreciate everyone taking the time to
to listen in and um you know feel free
to connect on on linkedin
or or wherever if there's any more
questions you have or you'd like to stay
in touch uh happy to connect
awesome well again thank you all so much
and have a great rest of your day please
feel free to reach out to our office if
you have any
remaining questions and we hope to see
you again at some of our other events
you